Mortal Kombat has been around since 1992
yes it's that old this could mean many
the people who play the game series are
younger than the franchise itself over
the next few weeks we'll be taking a
trip down memory lane and looking at the
original MK characters and how they've
evolved in their 10 video game outings
to be more specific in this episode
we'll be looking at 10 fatalities
scorpion has dished out over the years
back in 1992 an immaculately dressed man
spotting a lovely yellow and black
jumpsuit
she orders the destructive power of
Hellfire halitosis
scorpion when allowed to debate
color D less than 12 months later
scorpion was back to his antics this
time debuting his mortal kombat 3
arrived in 1995 and introduced a
terrible fatality for our hero he
somehow summons numerous versions of
himself which run towards their victim
but before anything can happen the
screen fades to black hands-down the
laziest fatality of the year
come on Midway of your game in 97 mid
where did indeed up their game and
brought forth the first fully 3d MK game
scorpion ruining lawn fatality ideas
decides to become a scarf unit to kill
his prey it's a good thing he wasn't
present the five-year hiatus was brought
to an end in 2002 when Mortal Kombat
Deadly Alliance arrives more ridiculous
fatalities were added but scorpion kept
to what he knew and removed his
opponents head without getting in this
wash zone in MK deception the man in
yellow and black resumed his passion for
removing limbs
but he's still considerate enough to end
any suffering quickly and effectively
what a guy
mortal kombat armageddon abandoned
fatalities for a terrible combat system
that simply didn't work luckily stage
phase scientists were still here and
scorpion Juli obliged
flawless victory in 2008 mortal kombat
joined forces with DC to create their
first versus title Superman could face
sub-zero Batman could go one-on-one with
Johnny Cage the fatalities were
deliberately lessened to give the game a
lowest possible age rating but scorpion
was still able to pull the Green Lantern
to help scorpion continued this theme
into Mortal Kombat 9
using his ability to switch dimension as
a center of his fatalities sub-zero
takes a quick trip to hell but didn't
survive the journey back last but
certainly not least in Mortal Kombat X
or model Kombat 10 I'm still not certain
how I'm supposed to pronounce that in
this the latest edition of the franchise
scorpion is in the possession of a
gut-wrenching fatality which has
something for everyone so that was the
evolution of scorpion what do you think
of those fatalities did we miss your
favorites
let us know in the comments below or
find us on twitter @ PS grenade as
always please like and share and please
subscribe to because that would really
help the channel out thanks for your
time we'll see you next time